[Música]
se conoce como la isla intensa a 10.000
kilómetros de Francia continental las
reuniones con de tesoros que no se dejan
descubrir fácilmente por cualquiera
caminando por los senderos empinados de
Mont longeva a 2.380 metros de altura
podemos descubrir paisajes poco comunes
de una diversidad excepcional
acantilados abruptos rocas volcánicas y
vegetación única
decepción la excepción reunionesa es ser
una isla oceánica volcánica tropical de
3000 metros de altura en la mitad del
océano Índico que fue generada por los
montes de África Asia e India
40% del territorio está clasificado como
patrimonio Mundial de la humanidad un
orgullo y una responsabilidad para los
reunioneses conservar esta naturaleza
intacta Es la primera vez que venimos
aquí efectivamente Hay que hacerlo no
nos tomamos el tiempo justamente de
descubrir Buscar saber cómo hacer para
preservar esto para las futuras
generaciones y es lamentable
entre los tesoros por preservar la vida
submarina a recibes coralinos delfines
tortugas y más de miles especies de
pescados diferentes que habitan las
aguas turquesas de la reunión
pero hoy no son los pescados los que les
interesan a Yuli y Adrián especialistas
en el mundo submarino
su misión recuperaron un objeto
particularmente valioso fijado en esta
losa de concreto a 30 metros de
profundidad
el hidrógeno una grabadora de sonido
ubicada al fondo del océano hacia dos
meses es el único hidrófono en la
reunión que graba los cantos de las
ballenas actualmente Entonces si las
perdemos solo aquí están guardadas es
por ello que es valioso para nosotros
Porque para la investigación los
estudios que hacemos Es importante solo
tenemos un afán abrir los archivos y
descubrir lo que las ballenas cantaron
este año
las ballenas jorobadas son las reinas de
estas aguas cada año entre abril y
noviembre suben desde la Antártico para
reproducirse en las aguas de la reunión
un espectáculo único cuyo rastro sonoro
les permite a los científicos conocer
mejor a estos mamíferos para protegerlos
vamos a ver a la ballena que hace esta
nota va hacia los agudos y desciende una
segunda nota totalmente diferente que
pasa de los agudos a los graves un poco
como una puerta que rechina y otra más
larga un poco más estable entonces ahí
terminó como una frase y la repite igual
justo después
el canto es para reproducirse es
realizado únicamente por los machos y
solo en los periodos del Invierno
austral que acaba de terminarse donde
las ballenas vienen para dar a luz y
aparearse
las dos hipótesis principales es que o
el canto le permite al macho atraer a
una hembra un poco como una serenata o
los machos hacen un concurso de canto y
es el que canta un poco más fuerte el
que tendrá dicho privilegio Mejor aún
la reunión tierra de contrastes cerca al
azul del océano bajo el verde de la
vegetación se esconde una raíz naranja
cuyo polvo es muy apreciado la cúrcuma
en la planilla de los Greg
el granero de especies de La Isla es
cosechada con la fuerza de los brazos
una cosecha no mecanizable que empujó a
los campesinos abandonar la cúrcuma por
otras hembras Como por ejemplo de caña
de azúcar Solo el padre de Cirilo no ha
renunciado a ello y pretende continuar
con el trabajo
aquí
color que Mancha
que mancha los dedos y el cuchillo
se necesitan dos años para que las
raíces alcancen el tamaño adecuado se
compone de dos partes con nombres
evocadores aquí se ve la madre con los
dedos aquí también hay una madre y dos
dedos separamos la madre y los dedos
porque los dedos sirven para hacer
cúrcuma estándar que es la más usada en
especial para la cocina
usamos la madre por sus virtudes
medicinales antiinflamatorias
antioxidantes principalmente
y hay que saber que también la usamos en
la cocina pero de verdad hay que echar
muy poco porque genera mucho color
amarillo
[Música]
luego la cúrcuma es lavada siete veces
picada y Secada al sol y es así que
ciril la prefiere Bueno es más cansada
Un poco más de paciencia y la cúrcuma se
transformará en este polvo un producto
excepcional uno de los numerosos tesoros
de la reunión
[Música]